chat DPT and googlebot are the two ah
chatbots you must have heard about they
bought an immense change in the way we
operate now from web development to
digital marketing from cloud computing
to cyber security they are now
everywhere you just name it and they
have it trust me the use of these
chatbots has changed everything now if
you want to create a complete YouTube
video just ask them and rest the show
they'll take care for your task not just
that but if you want to create a search
engine optimized content whether it be
for your website or on YouTube these AI
tools can help you with such content
search engine optimization is not easy
it takes a lot to optimize your content
so that people can get to see it on top
what are these AI tools threat to people
engaged in search engine optimization in
this video we'll not discuss what these
AI tools can do for you but we'll
discuss if AI tools like chat GPT or
Google bar will take over SEO or not but
before that if you enjoy watching these
videos and find them interesting please
subscribe to our Channel because we
bring the best videos for you daily hit
the Bell icon to get notified whenever
we drop a new video also if you wish to
create your own AI tool by gaining
expertise in the field of AI and machine
learning then simply learns Ai and
machine learning bootcamp is the right
choice for you with this boot camp you
will gain expertise in artificial
intelligence and machine learning by
learning the top skills required in this
to be not just that but there are many
other attractive features of this boot
camp like 25 plus Hands-On projects
across industry verticals with
integrated Labs will help you understand
the concepts better industry relevant
Capstone projects in three domains make
sure that you have mastered this
technology a bootcamp certificate from
Caltech ctma is worth mentioning in your
scene live virtual classes led by
industry experts Hands-On projects and
created labs simple learns career
service is here to help you get noticed
by the top hiring companies several
other features are also there in this
boot camp in simple terms this Ai and
machine learning boot camp helps you
become an expert in artificial
intelligence and machine learning a few
of the skills you will Master with this
program are supervised learning
unsupervised learning recommendation
networks deep learning chat GPT and much
more so hurry up and enroll Now find the
AI and machine learning bootcamp program
Link in the description box so let's
start this video with a small
introduction to search engine
optimization the goal of SEO is to make
a website more visible and bring in
income from natural traffic it entails
crafting excellent content for a
specific audience and optimizing a
website for search engines online
marketers employ AI to accomplish
various tasks such as keyword research
content optimization and Link building
more quickly businesses can boost their
ranks and increase their revenue by
using AI in SEO strategies additionally
by automating routine processes it can
save time and resources also if you want
to master the field of search engine
optimization and digital marketing
simply learns postgraduate program in
digital marketing is clearly the right
choice for you this postgraduate program
in collaboration with Purdue will help
you master search engine optimization
content marketing web analytics keyword
management and research website
management and optimization URL
management search psychology keyword
research Advanced ad features and move
not only these skills but you will also
learn a number of tools like SC ranking
hootsu Google ads Keyword Planner and
much more so hurry up and find the
course Link in the description box for
more details hear it from our Learners
who have experienced massive success in
digital marketing through this course
I moved to the United States four years
ago to live with my family
a background in social media by doing
the same was difficult here
more so because my English is not that
good last year I decided to pursue the
professional certification program in
digital marketing from Purdue University
offered by simple learner I like that it
could provide such as flexible schedule
for attending the live classes it came
with a recorded feature with a blessing
for working professionals like me tell
me make significant progress I am
already using these kids to sell my
products online I believe that I have
come one step closer to living my dream
life in America so let's talk about SEO
developments with chat GPT and Google
bar and notably the influence AI is
anticipated to have on search engines
have been highlighted by the recent
launches of Google's bar and chat Deputy
assistant bin although these recent
advancements pose a severe dungeon they
also present opportunities for digital
marketers to seize in the world full of
SEO things change all the time and Subs
are never stable the page that a search
engine displays as a result of a user's
search query is known as the search
engine result pitch or server this is
why it's important to be able to change
with the times and benefit from new
technological developments digital
marketers increasingly use AI for
keyword research heading ideas and
content optimizations this is so they
can concentrate on the jobs that need
human interaction small sites May
produce original SEO friendly material
much more quickly with chat GPT then
they could without it for instance
however it's vital to remember that this
is only a portion of the process it can
assist you with creating and providing
meta descriptions and titles keyword
research heading recommendations for
pages and posts article ideation and
composing copy so let's talk about the
role of AI in keyword research every
business utilizes AI to increase
productivity automate labor intensive
operations and make data driven choices
numerous Industries including finance
and banking e-commerce retail media
gaming research space exploration
Transportation automative medicine
manufacturing security and uses it in
various ways the Google AdWords Keyword
Planner and the Google Trends tool are
two of the most widely used free
artificial intelligence keyword research
tools you may find keywords with a lot
of search volume and little competition
using these tools another crucial aspect
to take into account when choosing
keywords for your website is intent this
is so because users frequently have a
purpose while searching for goods and
services although it might be
challenging to ensure your website
appears high on search engine visual
Pages especially with Google's algorithm
adjustments SEO companies and marketers
must constantly check their websites to
make sure that their websites are not
falling in the servers they can use AI
to automatically analyze search traffic
statistics and website content to spot
potential issues before they arise they
can then address these problems and
offer consistent organic rankings this
is a game changer for SEO companies and
marketers who realize on manual SEO
efforts to get traffic to their websites
but the main question is will charge GPT
or googlebot take over SE the answer is
clearly a big why chat Bots like chat
deputy and Bart cannot replace SEO they
can help generate content for your
website or video but SEO involves more
than just content creation it includes
tasks keyword research link building and
Technical SEO where you'll need an SEO
expert because chatbots can't decide how
to build links and which links will get
you more organic traffic SEO is
constantly changing due to search engine
algorithms search engines like Google
and Bing regularly update their
algorithms making SEO a dynamic field
SEO requires human judgment and decision
making the end of discussion because
determining which keywords to Target and
which links to build required expertise
and human decision making a chatbot
can't do it in fact the real power of
search engine optimizations lie is not
in their mechanical abilities but in
their creativity and ability to
understand what people are searching for
and why that's something that AI
Technologies may never be able to
replicate and it's what makes human SEO
experts such a valuable asset so while
it's true that AI Technologies may
eventually be able to take over some of
the aspects of SEO there's still plenty
of rooms for human experts to thrive
whether you are a seasoned SEO
professional or just starting out here's
still a place for you in this exciting
and ever evolving field let's keep an
eye on the developments in AI technology
and see how it can augment and enhance
our skills rather than replacing them
entirely who knows with the power of AI
and human expertise combined the future
of SEO may be even brighter than we can
imagine so with that we have come to the
end of this discussion although everyone
can have different opinions on this but
I hope you guys must have got an idea
Knight why these AI tools are not a
threat to SC if you still have any
questions or doubts let us know in the
comment section below and our team of
experts will help you at your list thank
you so much for being here today we'll
see you next time until then stay safe
and keep learning with simply learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here